d'inconduites sexuelles visant
le cardinal. C'est ce que nous
apprend un bref communiqué
du Vatican. Flavie Sauvageau.
- Le Vatican annonce
qu'il ne donnera pas suite
à l'enquête déclenchée
sur les allégations d'agressions
sexuelles qu'aurait commises
le Cardinal Marc Ouellet
entre 2008 et 2010.
Ces allégations figurent
dans une action collective
contre le diocèse de Québec.
ALAIN ARSENAULT, avocat
responsable, action collective
- Je suis un peu déçu,
mais je ne suis pas quand même
surpris, compte tenu que c'est
la tradition de l'Église
depuis tout le temps de nier,
nier, nier.
- En 2021, le Vatican a été
informé d'allégations sexuelles
concernant Marc Ouellet.
Le père Jacques Servais,
qui a déjà collaboré avec
le cardinal Ouellet, avait été
mandaté par le souverain
pontife. Il s'est entretenu
avec la victime alléguée.
Maintenant que son enquête
préliminaire est terminée et
après d'autres consultations
pertinentes, le pape François
a déclaré qu'il n's
d'éléments suffisants pour
ouvrir une enquête canonique
pour agression sexuelle
par le cardinal Ouellet.
Une déception pour la partie
plaignante et pour d'autres
victimes.
- C'est certain qu'on va
demander une copie une copie un,
et là, on va être capable
d'y répondre, mais peut-être
qu'entre-temps, on va avoir
un procès.
SÉBASTIEN RICHARD, porte-parole
des victimes de religieux
- Ce sont des disciples
de Jésus, c'est des gensqui sone
le bon sens. Bien non, c'est pas
ça qui arrive. Ça marcche, alors
qu'est-ce qu'il nous reste pour
obtenir justice, ça nous obligee
à aller devant les tribunaux.
- Pour cet expert, la décision
du Vatican pourrait s'expliquer
par des motifs plus complexes,
comme la difficulté de juger
de ces agressions depuis
l'étranger.
LOUIS ROUSSEAU, prof. retraité,
sciencesions, UQAM
- Le Vatican veut laisser
les processus judiciaires
québécois et canadiens
fonctionner. Le Vatican fait
confiance à notre système
de droit et notre système
de justice.
- Il pense que le Saint-Siège
l'enquête si de
nouveaux éléments lui
parviennent. Cependant,
l'impact des allégations
se fait déjà sentir, selon
- Dans un éventuel conclave
au cours des mois prochains pour
l'élection d'un nouveau pape,
que la ca que la ca que la ca e
Ouellette est maintenant brûlée.
Quel que soit le jugement,
les cardinaux ne prendront
aucune ce sujet-le sujet-le suj.
- Quant à ceux qui estiment
avoir été victimesons
sexuelles de la part de membres
du clergé, les avocats
leur conseillent de se tourner
vers le système de justice,
plutôt que vers les instances
religieuses.
Ici Flavie Sauvageau,
Radio-Canada, Qué